- All right.
We are almost outta time, y'all
but let's squeeze in one more
inspiring story before we go.
This is what I'm liking.
(rock music)
Middle school is a tough age.
I hated middle school,
which is why what I'm about
to share is truly special.
A seventh grader noticed his classmate
was getting bullied for his appearance
and wanted to do something about it.
So 12-year-old, Melo, decided he wanted
to give his classmate, Melvin,
a pair of sneakers to cheer him up.
And he even offered to give
up his Christmas presents
and allowance to do so,
and Melo followed
through on his commitment.
He even gave Melvin
the sneakers at school.
The story would've ended there,
except the dean saw Melvin
actually carrying the box.
And when he learned about this
story, he took this picture.
Folks, this is what kindness looks like.
We can be better humans.
Let's pay attention to our youth.
Melo and Melvin are with us right now.
What's up, y'all?
(audience cheering)
- Hi.
- What's up?
Melo, I'm gonna start with you.
Like why was doing this
so important to you?
- Doing this was so important to me.
When I saw Melvin getting bullied in class
it really hurt me in a way
because when I was younger
I got bullied because of my height.
So I called my mom after school
and let her know how I was feeling
and how everything going on
with Melvin made me feel.
And we went and got Melvin
a pair of shoes immediately
and then the next day I gave it to him.
And I was happy to see
the reaction of Melvin
that he was so happy.
- Oh my gosh, I love that.
So Melvin, those are some
pretty cool kicks, man.
You like your shoes?
- Yes, I love the shoes
and I'm very grateful for
what Melo did for me.
I wish other kids could
be just like Melo
helping others out.
- Absolutely.
You're absolutely right.
And not only by the way,
like Melvin, not only kids,
but a grown adult.
Like we can all learn a
lesson from this, you know?
It's a beautiful thing
to do something nice for someone
and it's also a lesson for
like all the bullies out there.
Like stay on your own front porch.
Quit worrying about ours.
Anyway, thank you so much.
I'm liking your post right now.
(audience clapping)
And that's not all, you guys.
Our season long partner, Pilot Pen,
makers of G2, the go-to pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show"
want to honor inspiring
kids just like y'all.
So they're gonna be writing you a check
to each of you for $500.
(audience cheering)
- There's no way.
Yes.
- Thank you.
- Oh my God, that was
the greatest reaction.
Oh my God, Melvin.
Melvin, you win for
greatest reaction ever.
He left.
He left the screen.
He was like, bye.
Oh my God, I love you guys.
Keep being amazing humans, all right.
And thank you to all our
guests today this hour.
Kristin Chenoweth, Khris
Davis, Isaiah, Matchbox Twenty,
and a huge thank you to Jude and Isaiah
and my music director,
Jason Halbert, who I love.
Have a great day, y'all.
If it's not great, try and change it.